Bộ giáo dục và đạo vừa ban thành công và số 4 nghìn 4 tâm mấy người các sử giáo dục và đạo thạo.
Về việc cóp ý chương trình trình sự của một số 1 học.
Theo Bộ giáo dục và đạo thạo.
Tại thời điểm này, cả nước đã thực hiện sắp sẽ cắt đơn vị hành chính.
Về thêm đổi địa giới hành chính và thực hiện chính quyền 2 cấp ảnh vưởng chức tiếp đến chương trình của 1 một 1 học.
Lịch sự và địa lý tự lốc 1 để lốc chính, địa lý lốc 12,
lý xử lốc 12 và giáo dục công dân lốc 12.
Về ban thành thông tư sự đổi.
Bộ giáo dục phổ thông ban thành công theo thông tư số 12.5,
hành hành hành hành hủ trăm mấy tám của Bộ giường giáo dục và đạo thạo.
Bảo đảm cho chương trình giáo dục phổ thông cập nhận được những lỗi dung phụ hợp với sự thay đổi.
Bảo đảm tính kho học và tính thực tế của các muốn học trong chương trình giáo dục phổ thông.
Về ban thành thông tư sự đổi.
Bộ giáo dục phổ thông là cân cứ pháp lý để xem sẽ chính xử xác xác xác cho phụ hợp với thực tế.
Bộ giáo dục và đạo đình giáo dục và đạo tạo tụ trước các í dự thảo chương trình trình xử của các muốn học như trên chương mấy mừng tám tháng tám.